we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
here is one of my favorite voicemail
types
and it is when someone tells me
i should really go to communist
countries if i love them so much
ignoring the fact that i have no
interest in communism or communist
countries take a listen
yeah i just heard your comments on the
trump rally right i think you really
need to try
try something like a special exercise
you know like a knee squat reach far
back because you can't with both hands
try to hold on to your ears or cat find
your ears and hold on to them and pull
your head out of your rear end i'm
having trouble picturing this but let's
continue
you're obviously one of those liberals
that's
got gay tendencies and gay tendencies
it's like what what is what does that
even have to do with anything
it's always anti-semitic or homophobic
at its core
very on american go to a communist
country and live there and see how you
like it there this is so funny because
as many of you know
much of my audience hates that i'm not a
communist but i'm not a communist i'm
not interested in communist countries
stalinist leninism is not something i'm
a fan of uh chavez maduro i'm not a fan
you know what however you want to
define
the ideal socialist or communist kind of
what whatever
that's not me
find someone else i i'm not interested
in that i'm interested in
uh capitalist northern european
democracies i'm interested yeah come on
guys give me a break but as usual
somewhere in there is some homophobia in
this case sometimes it's anti-semitism
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we'll talk about the neil young
joe rogan spotify uh debacle we will
talk about the heart transplant denial
due to no covet vaccine that many of you
have written to me about and much more
all of those stories on today's bonus
show sign up at joinpakman.com to get
instant access